Please welcome back to the show, Rosie Perez!
(upbeat music)
(audience cheers)
Hi.
So happy to see you!
So, happy to see you too.
Oh, stop it.
No, no, no, no, stop it.
Stop it.
I can't help it.
Oh, wow.
Thank you.
I wore a pants suit for you.
I am noticing your fashion.
I am picking it up the second you walked out.
I love this color green.
Monochromatic suits are trending.
Are they?
Yes, so you're super on trend.
(man shouts indistinctly)
Yes, exactly.
(crowd cheers)
That is fashion aspiration at its finest.
This is Christian Siriano, so.
Oh I love Christian Siriano!
And I was just staring at his Instagram on Oscar night,
and you were wearing his gown on the Oscars.
Yes, yeah.
He made it for me.
I wanted to be in black and he was like,
"No, you're gonna do red."
I go, "No, I'm gonna do black."
And he was like, "You're doing red."
And so I was like, "You can't tell me what to do."
He goes, "Yes, I can.
You're gonna do red."
And so when I saw the dress, I was like, "Wow."
(crowd cheers)
It's so beautiful.
Oh, thank you.
I told him that I wanted to look, you know, sexy,
but I wanted to look grown up sexy.
I didn't wanna try to compete with the younger girls
because I like being my age.
And I mean, it's so funny when we start to say like,
we did "Riding in Cars with Boys" Together,
this beautiful film that I hold so dear to my heart.
How long ago was that?
What, 20 years ago?
Probably, yeah.
Maybe even longer.
Yeah.
I'm not kidding.
And then, how long ago was, "White Men Can't Jump"
One of the greatest films ever made?
I was so excited to see that reunion.
I still say in my head, almost on a daily basis,
"Foods that start with the letter Q."
I still, I don't know why but that is always in my head.
It was 30 years.
30 years.
Yeah, and it was so good to see them
because I had not seen Woody Harrelson and Wesley Snipes
for maybe seven years.
'Cause we're still friends, you know, but we, you know,
our lives get busy and everything like that.
So when I saw them the first day, it was the day
before the event, it was just like old times.
And we were just kidding and laughing around,
and then the night of the Oscars, I saw Wesley's outfit,
which was fabulously ridiculous.
And I said, "What do you think Woody's gonna wear?"
And he goes, "He's gonna look like a hot mess."
And I said, "No!"
And then Woody walks in and Wesley and I
just started cracking up and Woody goes, "What's the joke?"
And then Wesley said, "Nothing, you just look like
an undertaker at the Oscars, but you're good.
You're good."
And yeah, 'cause the suit did not fit him well.
I'm sorry to say, I love you, I love you, Woody, but.
I love it.
I mean, you in that film, boy did you just show everybody
how invaluable the woman is?
Aww.
You were the biggest force in that movie.
And that changes things.
It really does.
It's important when somebody is that dynamic
and the film would just fall apart without them.
It's like, oh, you're so good in that movie.
You were such a revelation.
Thank you.
I'm bugging out right now.
Why?
Because, we'd known each other forever
and it's weird to sit here as two grown women
who are doing their things, and don't get me crying,
don't do it, don't do it, don't do it.
I'm just so proud of you.
(crowd cheering)
(applause)
Oh my God.
You know what I mean?
I do.
Longevity, we're still here!
That's right, baby!
(crowd cheering)
(applause)
I'm so lucky to have this opportunity.
(upbeat music)